- All right y'all we always
like to close out the hour
with something that might make you smile.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music and audience cheering)
Generally when you think of a bird watcher
you fully envision someone with
binoculars deep among trees.
Maybe a bucket hat resting
on their head looking rad.
And plenty of people, sure they
enjoy ornithology that way.
That's the study of birds.
I'm really intelligent.
(audience laughs)
And perhaps learned
that word this morning.
(Audience laughs)
But a woman in upstate New
York known as Bird Lady Drin
wanted a different experience.
Something more up-close and
more personal, so check out what she did.
(orchestral music)
(audience cheers)
It's one way to do it.
Let's get this innovative
naturist on the line.
What's up Bird Lady Drin?
(audience cheers)
- Hello, hi. It's so good to see you.
[Kelly] You are so cute.
I love this so much but
before we talk about that
face-feeder invention, you
study birds for a living, right?
[Bird Lady Drin] Absolutely.
I am a wild bird research
technician which basically means
that I go out into the wild
I humanely capture wild
birds and I study them.
- That's cool.
[Bird Lady Drin] And
about a year ago I made a
TikTok account and recently I
had been tagged a whole bunch
of times in this video where
this guy who feeds hummingbirds
has all these contraptions on his face.
And I was like, you know
what? I think I can do that.
So I went downstairs and I
found the only pair of glasses
that I had laying around.
Which were these with
these eyelashes on them.
And I made this little face-feeder
and sat outside for about
45 minutes all bundled up in my blanket.
And then a bird came and
I've been hooked ever since.
[Kelly] Oh my God. I mean,
do you, how long does it
generally take for a
bird to do that though?
Do you have to sit there for hours often?
[Bird Lady Drin] Sometimes.
Sometimes can take any anywhere
from just a minute or two
to up to three hours.
And so I sit outside in
you know, minus freezing
temperatures and I'm all bundled
up in either my blanket or
my ghillie suit that I went out and I got.
And I just sit and I watch and I wait.
And what you guys don't get
to see is that the birds
are all around me, hopping
around, talking to each other.
And it's like my own
little private nature show.
And so it's just, it's
amazing and I'm hooked.
[Kelly] I love it.
(audience cheers)
You make me smile! Thank
you so much Bird Lady Drin!
I'm liking your posts
right now, all right?
[Bird Lady Drin] Thank you.
(bell dings)
[Kelly] All right, well
that's not all girl.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson show.
They wanna celebrate
those creating fearlessly
just like you ma'am.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
- Oh my gosh, thank you.
[Kelly] Absolutely. Thank you so much!
Good luck with the birds!